Now, we should be pretty happy, we've got the guts of our program working. We've
tested it, we've got some confidence this is going to work correctly. But we've
got a problem, we're not getting the right answers. And we're not getting the
right answers, because not all months have 30 days. We've tried to put off this
grungy detail of dealing with the reality of the real world and most
computational problems in the real world eventually run into issues like this
that aren't that interesting, but are very complex. So now, we've gotta deal
with the complexity of how many days there actually are in a month, that's the
only thing we have left to deal with. One of the good ways about solving the
problem this way is we got close to an answer without dealing with all that
complexity, but we've gotta deal with it at some point, and now is the time that
we have to deal with it.